[Musique]
je m'éveille vers les midi elle est là
qui me dit bonjour
chéri devant moi il y a du thé et des
croissants des confitures et du pain de
[Musique]
et puis elle me prend la main et me
sourit et me demande si j'ai bien
dormi partout où mes yeux se poses je
n'aperçois que les roses de la
vie si ce n'est pas de
l'amour alors je vous le
[Musique]
dire dieu n'a pas créé les petites
souris et l'enfant que j'étais ne croyez
pas au Père
Noël Paris est au bord de la mer et l'on
veut voir de nuit l'Angleterre de la
tour et
[Musique]
felle l' dieu n'a pas créé les petites
souris et il ne tombe pas une goutte
d'eau en normand
les cocolicos sont tout blevés quand il
fait froid et même quand ils pleut on
est tous
ravis parfois dans la journée
j'appelle je sais qu'elle est
là je lui demande de venir me
rejoindre n'importe où dans la vie
elle s'habille prend d'xi
elle arrive à l'heure et moi je suis en
[Musique]
retard si ce n'est pas de
l'amour alors je vous le dis
[Musique]
dieu n'a pas créé les petites souris et
ce matin j'ai rencontré le Roi Soleil au
[Musique]
tuilerie dans les journaux de ce matin B
nous dit on affirme que tout va bien
dans tous les
pays mon Dieu na pas cré les petites
souris et il ne tombe pas une goutte
d'eau en Normandie
les CIC sont dou quand il fait froid et
même quand il pleuent on est tous
ravis c'est
[Musique]
tout